salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique aujourd'hui une fois
n'est pas coutume on va parler cinéma
alors est ce que vous vous intéressez à
l'angleterre est ce que vous vous
intéressez à la politique anglaise
est-ce que vous intéresser or existe si
oui eh bien j'ai le film parfait pour
vous et sinon eh bien j'ai tout de même
un film avec benedict cumberbatch ce
film cbre exit un film qui nous
racontent l'aventuré qualité le
référendum pour savoir si le royaume uni
devait rester ou non au sein de l'union
européenne on y suit notamment le comité
propres exit et surtout son dirigeant et
stratège dominique que ming incarné à
l'écran par benedict cumberbatch
dominique cummings c'est un conservateur
c'est un second couteau dans la
politique anglaise mais c'est surtout
quelqu'un d'un peu particulier il est
certes conservateur mais pas au sens
classique du conservatisme autorise
anglais c'est quelqu'un qu'on peut
considérer comme étant un libertarien de
droite avec une forme de mentalité un
peu comme celle de la silicon valley à
savoir tourné vers l'innovation vers la
technologie vers la rationalité et qui
croient en une forme de méritocratie
basé sur l'intelligence est une forme de
darwinisme social également c'est
quelqu'un qui ne supportent pas
l'establishment anglais qu'ils soient
travaillistes conservateurs et qui ne
supporte pas les fabriques à élite comme
oxford ou cambridge alors même que lui
même est issu d'oxford c'est quelqu'un
qui en fait tu veux casser le moule
traditionnel anglais pour adapter la
société au 21ème siècle ou du moins
l'adapter selon ses vues libertariennes
et quand les progrès qu'ils vont aller
le chercher un petit peu à reculons
parce qu'ils connaissent sa réputation
d' homme excentrique et un petit peu
mégalomane et bien il va accepter de
diriger ce comité propres exit parce
qu'ils y voient une façon potentiel est
bien d'allumer la mèche pour faire
exploser les carcans de la société
anglaise traditionnelle et
potentiellement il vient de réaliser ses
rêves d'une nouvelle société d'ailleurs
cette attitude assez particulière et ce
caractère vont finir par lui jouer des
tours au delà du président car quand
boris johnson finira par accéder au
poste de premier ministre il le prendra
comme
conseiller spécial et à force de se
mettre tout le monde à dos par ses idées
et bien il sera détesté par
l'establishment conservateur et finira
par être viré comme un malpropre
alors ce film est intéressant pour les
prêts existants lui-même pour ce que
l'on voit de la machine référendaire
mais il est aussi intéressant au delà de
du royaume uni et de la question libre
existe en fait il ya certaines questions
qui se posent qui se posent dans toutes
les démocraties occidentales actuelles
la première question c'est celle de
savoir comment aujourd'hui dans notre
société technologique ont fait pour
gagner une élection où un référendum
cette question dans le film est
introduite via la question des
algorithmes et du de la campagne
numérique puisque bing c'est donc très
axé sur les questions technologiques il
va faire appel à une start-up aggregate
ique qui avec une base de données
notamment récupéré par cambridge
analytica à facebook de façon pas très
clair
vont pouvoir et bien cibler certains
électeurs qui passe actuellement
totalement en dessous des radars
traditionnels des partis politiques et
qui ne sont quelque part pas dans les
bases de données on parle de trois
millions de personnes et ainsi agrégats
take you va pouvoir faire des du
profilage et des campagnes micro cibler
des des thématiques qui peuvent
potentiellement intéresser chaque
électeur en particulier alors cette
cette question de fait pose question à
savoir si aujourd'hui est bien dans une
élection un référendum on a encore
besoin et bien des des militants c'est à
dire des gens qui vont coller les
affiches qui vont aller distribuer les
tracts ou si on a plutôt besoin
d'ingénieurs de serveurs de big data et
quelque part et bien le film répond à
cette question faut-il des petits bras
ou des grosses data et nous montre
clairement que les résultats livres
existent sont joué à peu de choses près
et qu' il est probable qu aggregate high
ku et c ces campagnes ciblées
extrêmement spécifique a probablement
contribué largement à la victoire des
pros brésil
donc ce que nous dit ce film quelque
part c'était bien on peut faire des
campagnes et quelque part sans 100
militants s'en sont partisans ce qui est
un petit peu particulier puisque nos
sociétés démocratiques repose aussi sur
l'engagement individuel et sur l'action
tu peux faire le partisan mais voilà en
tout cas pour pour cette question il ya
une deuxième question qui qui affleure
qui est celle de savoir qui est le plus
légitime pour porter une question dans
l'espace public qu'est ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est un peu un historique
de cette question où est ce que ça peut
être un outsider un peu plus frais cette
question elle est abordée à travers le
personnage de nigel farage donc un
progrès exit historique il veut
rejoindre le comité officiel dirigé par
koenig parce qu'il y avait un comité
officiel pro et un autre anti brigitte
qui avec plus de moyens et d'accès à
certains financements que les autres
petits comités qui pourraient se former
et que ming envoie bouler parce que bien
qu'ils considèrent que
farage l'élément un petit peu comique
c'est un personnage un peu truculent
dans le film voilà il estime que farage
ça fait des années qu'ils portent la
question du président qui est
caricatural qu'il est bloqué sur cette
question et que quelque part il nuit à
sa propre cause et de fait effectivement
c'est surtout le comité dirigé par
cummings avec une vision novatrice qui
ne s'adresse pas uniquement par exemple
sur la question de l'immigration comme
c'était un petit peu le cheval de
bataille de faradje mais plutôt sur les
questions économiques qui va contribuer
à la victoire du résultat cette question
elle a un écho je trouve en france
aujourd'hui à la droite de la droite
avec la question de savoir s'il faut
plutôt soutenir zemmour ou le pen c'est
à dire la famille qui historiquement
pour les questions d'immigration
d'insécurité de culture mais qui aussi
historiquement est celle qui depuis
bientôt 40 ans échoue à faire triompher
ses idées ou est-ce qu'il faut soutenir
l'outsider le nouveau cheval de course
qui aborde les questions une façon
différente qui permet de d'aller vers un
nouvel électorat qui donne quelque part
un nouveau souffle à ces questions et là
aussi le film au moins pour l'angleterre
nous dit clairement que oui ça ne sont
pas forcément les tenants historique
d'un d'une thématique qui sont les mieux
à même de la faire triompher également
avant de conclure ce film et bien c'est
un film qui est extrêmement politique
c'est un film qui se base sur l'histoire
réelle qui est quasiment un biopic il ya
eu des entretiens pour avec les
protagonistes historique pour faire
quelque chose de cohérent et qui soit le
plus près possible de la réalité donc
c'est pas un film très très glamour à
regarder avec des gens qui seraient pas
intéressés par la politique très
clairement
c'est le genre de film qui peut être
projeté en première partie de soirée sur
arte est suivie d'une deuxième partie
avec un un débat sur la question et du
brésil par contre c'est un film que l'on
peut regarder même si on connaît pas
grand chose à la politique anglaise
puisque tous les protagonistes sont
introduits on a leur nom leur fonction
leur parti politique s'ils sont pros en
titre existe donc là dessus on peut
regarder ce film même sens sont rien
connaître à l'angleterre
donc voilà un film sympathique qui
portent pas mal de questions politiques
au delà de l'angleterre et qui à mon
avis il faut voir et qu'il faut voir
chez nous avant la présidentielle de
2000 22 parce que eh bien il porte pas
mal de thématiques qui peuvent être en
lien avec chez nous cette élection qui
commence à focaliser un petit peu tout
le monde bref cette vidéo est maintenant
terminée si vous êtes intéressé
n'hésitez pas à la partager et à vous
abonner à la chaîne et sur ce je vous
dis à la prochaine